[Music]
[Applause]
talk to Charles Barkley here in a moment
we talked a little bit about Draymond
Green he's done it again this is what it
sounded like last
night field just picked up his third
foul and now green runs over nurkic and
he'll be called for the foul and they're
going to take a look at
this see Jason Goble indicating they
will go to the monitor here nurkic is
down in a
heap green just plows right over
nage Bo that is a swipe across the
face after video review green makes
unnecessary and excessive contact to the
face the F's been upgraded to a flagrant
foul penalty two and green has been
ejected from the game all right that's
courtesy of t NT it's bringing Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer also check out
King Charles with Gail King Wednesdays
at 10 Eastern on CNN a 1-hour talk show
with the co-host all right Chuck here we
are with Draymond Green yet
again what do the Golden State Warriors
do what's their role in this because it
feels like the commissioner can suspend
him and it does it
matter you know one of my one of my
favorite people in the world is Herm ATS
he's one of the great men not great
coaches one of the Great Men I ever
met and he would say hey you know what
the NFL is not g to do anything to you
but you know what my job is not just to
win football game my job is to teach you
to be a grown grown ass man he says I'm
gonna suspend
you uh I think the Golden State Warriors
you know CU Adam Adam what Adam doing
doing something really doesn't matter
but when you're your boss says hey you
know what it's time for us to sit you
down because you know you just lose
money when the league suspend you I
think you need to be embarrassed when
your boss says hey you know what you're
hurting the team I'm gonna do something
to you so I think it's up to the Golden
State Warriors say hey you know what
Draymond you've been great for this
organization been great for the team but
you're not worth the effort you know we
tired of dealing with this BS so I think
the Warriors need to step in and say hey
even even before Adam does anything
today because he's going to get
suspended if the Warriors came out and
said hey can we handle this situation I
think that would be the right thing to
do Dan personally yeah but I don't know
if you say all right we're gonna suspend
you for 10 games I I don't think
Draymond can be embarrassed and I think
that's part of the problem that you cost
your team uh you know with the
suspension in the NBA Finals the number
of times like 20% of the games I think
he's been thrown out of this year I mean
he's he's become an embarrassment for
the NBA maybe the Golden State Warriors
go hey he's a necessary evil
here not anymore you it's a necessary
evil when you're winning not when you're
losing and he's frustrated because he
can't play the way he used to
play that's probably what what as a
player that's what I'm saying I'm like
oh man because I'm not saying this cuz I
like everybody likes Draymond but Dan I
started doing stupid stuff when I
couldn't play anymore it was very
frustrating you like my last two years
with the Rockets I sucked as a player
you know I actually hit Ella Harrington
nobody knows about it otella Harrington
I hit him in practice because he was
working so hard and there was nothing I
could do about it so I took him I threw
him down and Rudy Tom Johns Who I Really
respect is we're gonna we're gonna vote
and you're not gonna play and I was
humiliated but it was because I couldn't
play anymore so I was playing dirty I
see the same thing with Draymond he's
not the same player and he's frustrated
but one thing about be you have to go
old gracefully because he's accomplished
a lot in this game but when you can't
play anymore it's very frustrating and
that's what you see now from him that's
what I see as a player and they let him
talk after the game I would think if you
got kicked out of a game
that they wouldn't have you on the
podium but I mean he loves the attention
yeah but Dan I'm going tell you
something I I know there something that
he does and you can just tell he always
says you know I'm not going to apologize
for anything that's his goto response
I'm like no dude because he said the
same thing last time he was suspended he
said well I'm not gonna change I'm not
going to apologize he said the exact
same thing last night I'm like yeah
that's a flaw bro you letting people
down it's all right to say one of the
biggest problem with celebrities today
Dan not just Draymond they afraid to say
hey you know what I really screwed up
it's my fault they have the handlers
like write these stupid statements and
things like that I tell them I said it's
all right to say hey you know what I was
wrong but nobody wants to do that
Draymond needs to say You know what last
time I got suspended I was wrong I was
wrong for what I did tonight and I don't
know if he has the pride he need to say
hey you know what I was wrong and I let
my team down again that's what he needs
to say none of that hey I'm not going to
change I'm who I am what I am no that
doesn't work anymore because you're not
the same player you know Bill cow is
somebody I really
admire we're talking about Chip Kelly
one day when he he cut all his good
players when he got trated to the um
when he took over for the Eagles and
Bill KY somebody who called me he says
hey you know Chip Kelly I said no I
never met Chip Kelly he says tell him
quit cutting all his good players
because he don't like him this is not
like college you can just roll another
two star three star out there he says
sometime your players are you
just have to deal with them I mean Bill
Bill car I tell I love bill carard but
he said he said he called me out of the
blue and I mean I know him but he called
me out says please tell Chip kellet this
is the pros this is not College you
don't you can't even though you don't
like a guy you put up with a guy cuz he
cut Deshawn Jackson n k Shan McCoy cuz
he didn't like him I said he said tell
him this is not Oregon you don't have to
like your players he did he said you
don't have to like your players but you
have to deal with when you
coaching today it was really a funny
conversation we're talking to Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer you can check
out King Charles with Gail King
Wednesday nights at 10 Eastern on CNN
but I think the Golden State Warriors
are culpable in this they're complicit
because if I go back to the Jordan pool
moment when Draymond punches him nobody
rushes to Draymond and like what are you
doing like they didn't do anything they
all just kind of like Meandering like
this maybe you know Jordan P had it
coming or Draymond does this kind of
stuff and they kept him and then they
got you know eventually got rid of
Jordan p and I'm sure he's emboldened by
that well I think what happens Dan you
know this you see it all the time in
sports everybody always amazed and I
always laugh I man shut the hell up I
say if you a good player or great player
you can get away with murder and nobody
says anything as long as you're winning
the problem what's happening with
Draymond now is they're not winning
anymore but Dam when you win players can
get away with anything that's that I
always I'm amazed when the public be all
oh I'm outraged I'm like why are you
outrage when you're winning you can do
whatever the hell you want to do but
like I say the problem with Draymond now
is they're not winning that team's not
any
good but you know there's nothing they
can really do they're struck with him I
think he's sign a four-year
extension and so he's he's gonna be
there yeah no matter what yeah uh last
night the Joker got thrown out on uh
Serbia
night the Bulls game in the second
quarter he gets tossed so you're
throwing out I I guess there's magic
words that you use that it's it's going
to be automatic that you're going to I
mean and don't use those words here but
are there automatic words if you say
that you will get a technical you may
get
tossed you know that's a great question
I'm not sure I've been tossed a few
times but I I
think I think only twice I got tossed
when I wasn't intentionally trying to
get tossed to be honest with you so I
just kept pushing pushing pushing when I
was trying to get toss but I don't think
there's no magic words but Joker had to
say something bad to get tossed on Seria
night uh or or the ref you know I don't
think CU you know he's such a great kid
and a great player I'd be curious
exactly what he said I'd be curious if
he cursed him out in Serbian or English
CA you know I I if you curse him out in
Serbia and the ref probably had no idea
what he said so uh I'd be curious to
know exactly what what Joker said to get
tossed on Ser at night did you play
against players who might have said
things to you a different language you
had no idea what they were saying to
you another great question I don't I
don't remember coach cursing me out I
mean I don't remember a player saying
anything crazy to me in a foreign
language but I probably would have
laughed if even if I thought it was it
was vulgar uh but no I don't remember
any player cursing me out in a foreign
language but that would have been flat
out hilarious I think you been you were
thrown out of 16
games that's it
well it's not exactly your Rasheed
Wallace here but I well because I know I
had a I I'm way up on the technicals
list I'm way up on the technicals list
but so 16 um but I probably 14 of those
I deliberately Tred to get
tossed but did you get fined or tossed
when you pulled down Shaq when you guys
were having that altercation anybody get
in trouble there we both got in trouble
with our moms sh
sha Shaq mom and my mom were best
friends and before we got to the locker
room they were already blowing up our
phone and yeah I used to get on my mom's
case all the time because my mom and
Shaq's mom and there's another lady Nam
Martha Corman they were like three trip
you to call them The Golden Girls they
would take like 25 vacations a
year and my mom would spend money like
Shaq's mom and I Shaq made 12 times the
money out made I'd call and yell at my
Mom I'd be like Mom why are y'all
staying at the Ritz in the Four Season
why can't y'all stay at a the W or or a
hotel six but they would always stay at
these great hotels I used to yell at my
Mom that's the only time I yelled at my
mom she stay that's Mom I didn't make
Shacks type money stay at a Motel 6 or
Weston or Hyatt somewhere like that you
don't have to stay at the risk callon or
the Four Seasons yeah I us to laugh all
the time I said Mom Shaq make a lot more
on to me Paulie uh how many techn
where's where's Charles on the technical
list okay this list I think is pretty
good top five with technical files five
is Rodman Gary pton with 250 Rasheed
Wallace with 317 Charles Barkley with
329 technical hey congratulations he
just got beat out by the mailman with
332 Carl Malone yeah I I knew I had
quite a few but like I say I probably
you say I got ejected like 15 times 16
times I think yeah yeah a 14 of those
were elaborate and twice I think they
they ref overreacted to me calling
names but why I'm wondering why you want
to get thrown out of a game you never
want to get thrown out of a game but you
just said you did it 14 times well
sometimes you know the ref is just so
bad or you it's a or the game's over you
know I think I think what one thing that
happens when guys are getting technicals
especially when you're a great player
you get a technical just to let them
know like hey I deserves some calls also
I think a lot because you know the guys
you mentioned Carl like me and Carl Carl
was a hell of a player great player like
sometimes you just want to get your
opponent view across so you want to get
a technical but you never really want to
get tossed but there's a couple times
proba of the game was over we were
getting our behind kicked you're like
hey you know what let me get in the damn
shower quickly and get this thing over
with but you never really want to get
tossed because you're going to hurt your
team like sometimes like you know you
see during the I give you an example Dan
you see a lot of times where coaches you
can see they're deliberately trying to
get technicals because the referee is
like you know what I gave him a
technical maybe I should give them some
calls cuz ref they're paying attention
also remember when Phil Jackson used to
whine all the time you know he know the
ref was watching TV or reading the
newspaper so this it's a psychological
game with the refs sometime CU some refs
are cowards on the road like if you go
to a hospital environment they're
intimidated by the Home crowd so you
have to stand up for yourself they
giving because they they hear everything
the crowd saying you hear it also as a
player and some refs we used to look
around we did not want certain refs on
the road because they were intimidated
like
who I'm not doing stop it Dan okay I
okay stop it I'm just being a journalist
how much do you celebrate winning the
inseason tournament if you're the Lakers
are you Dan are you serious right now
are you serious right now they're gonna
raise a banner Charles are you serious
right now now if you're the Pacers I
said you do a parade you do a banner in
the ceiling any reason to celebrate you
you do in season rings for the Pacers if
you win against the Lakers but let me
let me tell you something if the Pacers
do a End season parade I'm going to
Indie for that okay no we don't
you know it was a resounding success
yeah uh everybody's really happy with
the n Season tournament but we not
raising banners we're not doing parades
they were doing champagne with goggles
Charles you
know I'm so glad that I wasn't
watching uh I'm so glad that I wasn't
watching Saturday night if I saw them
doing champagne for the n Season
tournament like I say it was a
resounding sense but if the L uh you
don't do you don't do champagne for the
inseason tournament I'm glad I did not
see that I'm really glad I didn't see
that and then people on social media
said hey Jordan never won an inseason
tournament and LeBron has and I went he
didn't play in an inseason tournament
but how important would an inseason
tournament have been to
Jordan well I think all first of all you
just want to win the
games I don't think it would have been
uh listen I think it would have been a
better story personally if the Pacers
had a won because it was a it was a
really coming out party for theres
halberton he was fabulous unbeliev seems
like a great kid
also um but the Lakers they're the
Lakers there's two teams in the NBA that
Championship ABS matter to the Lakers
and the Celtics are the gold St standard
uh you can throw the Bulls in there a
little bit and the Spurs but if you're
the Lakers or the Celtics only thing
matter is more championship and listen
like I say it was a great success but
the n Season tournament I I really the
Lakers better not have a put up a in
seon I think they are that listen man if
they do that I'm gonna roast their ass
on TV you know we gonna have to talk
about it if they put that end season
tournament banner up Dan I'm going to
roast them on
television by the way the Bulls are
doing a Ring of Honor and that means
they're inviting Phil and Mike and
Scotty well I'm trying to figure
out first of all the Bulls are an
embarrassment to the NBA I have zero
idea what they're doing they should have
had a clearance Cale like three years
ago I I was like dude y'all stink y'all
stink y'all stink get rid get you got to
start I'm trying to figure out when
they're going to start to rebuild I like
and were they waiting on Michael and the
guys to die before they come up with the
Ring of Honor I mean don't they have a
statue out front I think you'd rather
have a statue than be in the Ring of
Honor no disrespect to being because I'm
in he's gonna have both he's gonna have
both but can you imagine Scotty and Mike
Crossing pass at the Ring of Honor hey
they're not going to do that on the same
night I guess no they are they are
they're inviting everybody is going to
be there and it's next month you know
what I gotta go I gotta go you might not
make it you might make it awkward even
more Awkward if you go no I'm just gonna
sit back in the corner and stare hey I'm
praying I think Golden State goes to
Chicago in mid January so Steve cerr
will be there please please don't have
the night I got to work because I want
to go there and be a fly on the wall
Paulie check and see I think it's like
January 12th that Golden State goes to
Chicago Ring of Honor Rodman Phil
Jackson Mike
Scotty uh maybe they should they
shouldn't do it on the same night
because that's the only way they gonna
go to crowd is on a ring of on night but
they should they should spread it out
they'll put they're putting all those
guys in there at the same night I think
so yeah Paulie yeah halftime on January
12th confirmed at the Bulls game in
bonus coverage Charles the Lakers will
unveil the NBA inseason tournament
Banner to be hung on uh December 18 yes
oh my God wait what night of the week is
the Bulls thing what is the January 12th
Friday Friday night I can be there I can
be there maybe you go with Michael
Jordan's
son
Dan I I I'm telling you something I'm
gon have to go to Chicago that they just
to just to see it I mean you talk about
weirdest
uncomfortable that uncomfortable won't
do it
justice I mean I
dude people people first of all nobody's
going to watch the Warriors or the Bulls
okay let's get that out the way nobody's
going to see The Warriors against Bulls
but everybody's gonna have their camera
focus on those guys I can't wait to
people are going to show up at right at
the end of this second quarter that's
exactly right they that's like they're
gonna go get all liquored up the first
half and they going to leave right after
half time yes yes just like you would I
there's no reason to watch the Bulls
against the uh the Warriors at
all thanks for getting up for us oh no
problem are we gonna see you in Vegas at
the
superbow Dan what I'm really having a
hard time with that decision cuz you
know me and my boys I take about 12 of
my boy
boys uh we've been to Vegas 26 straight
years for the Super Bowl oh I know you
blew us off in Arizona we were supposed
to go to your crib we're going to Vegas
we're going to be there now you're
saying you don't want to go to Vegas
well it's G to be so crowded and so many
people so I think I'm GNA have all 12 13
guys come to my house and stay at my
house so now you're going to be at your
house well because Dan we've been to
Vegas 26 straight years Vegas is the
best place in the world to watch the
Super Bowl and have fun for the weekend
and play golf and everything but now all
these losers are going to be there for
the Super Bowl so we we we I'm we're
gonna put it to a vote me and the 12
guys I've been with all these years
right now coming to Scottdale all stand
at my house is in the clubhouse lead
well you pay for everything so you
should be the only guy voting well we
don't know if I pay for stuff until
after the gambling is settled Dan you
get everything free in Vegas until after
the weekend so we don't know if I gotta
pay for everything yet great to talk to
you and good good luck with King Charles
all right brother hey man I appreciate
you you guys be safe and hey happy
holiday you too oh hey and happy
Hanukkah too oh for Todd yeah happy uh
uh really it was more for my son-in-law
screw
Todd very nice all right happy Hanukkah
guys at Christmas all right that's
Charles Berkeley King Charles with Gail
King tonight at 10 Eastern on CNN